Speaker 1: The latest thing now. On COVID
vaccines is that there are people trying to undo
their vaccination or reverse the vaccination
almost as if you were poisoned and you want
the antidote. The antidote now, of course, this is
all bogus nonsense B.S., but it's quite stunning
and I want to talk about it a little bit. Look at
this COVID vaccine holdouts are caving to mandates
and then scrambling to undo their shots. So there
are people who they don't want to lose a job or
they want to be able to go to wherever it is
anti-vaccine people like to go. And so they're
acquiescing and getting vaccinated, but then they
are reversing their vaccine. How are they doing
that? Well, it doesn't work. Check this out. This
is a very good NBC News article by Ben Collins
in a Tik Tok video that has garnered hundreds of
thousands of views. Dr. Carey Meadows outlined
the ingredients for a bath she said will detox the
vaccine for people who gave in and got vaccinated.
The ingredients in the bath are mostly not
harmful, although the supposed benefits are
entirely fictional. Baking soda and Epsom salts,
she falsely claims, will provide a radiation detox
to remove radiation meds falsely believes
is activated by the vaccine. There is about
four different things there that we could look at.
Bentonite clay will add a quote me major pull of
poison, she says, based on a mistaken idea and
anti-vax communities that toxins can be removed
from the body with certain therapies. Then she
recommends adding in a cup of Borax, a cleaning
agent that's been banned as a food additive by the
FDA, to quote Take nanotechnologies out of you. In
reality, in addition to being potentially harmful
as a skin, an eye irritant, a Borax detox bath
will not remove the effects of the COVID vaccine
from your body. So it's baking soda, Epsom salt,
bentonite clay and borax. I suggest adding in
cocoa powder and whole wheat flour. Bake it for 20
minutes and you'll have some really, really nice
muffins at the end of the day, OK? The video is
one of several methods anti-vax influencers have
suggested to followers. Anti-vax message boards
are now littered with users caving to societal
pressure work mandates. Once you're injected, the
life saving vaccination process has already begun.
You can't un ring a bell. It's just not physically
possible, says Angela Rasmussen, a virologist and
professor at University of Saskatchewan in Canada.
Detox remedies and regimens have been staples
of the anti-vax movement for years before COVID,
anti-vax influencers and alternative
health entrepreneurs promoted unproven,
sometimes dangerous treatments they claimed would
rid children of alleged toxins that lingered after
immunization. Children, many with autism, have
been subjected to these disproven cures by way
of parents convinced that they're alleviating
suffering caused by heavy metal poisoning from
vaccines. The often costly remedies have included
restrictive diets, supplements, chelation and
hyperbaric chambers, as well as dangerous home
remedies. Oh, and there's more. Now, some anti-vax
groups recommend people who have been vaccinated
immediately self-administer cupping therapy to
speed up the removal of vax content, including
first making small incisions on the injection site
with a razor. Other memes give instructions on how
to un inject shots using syringes. Both methods
are potentially dangerous and wouldn't actually
do what they claim to do. This is crazy. This is
straight up crazy. I saw a tweet from cultural
critic. The last real, liberal and arbiter of
ideas, Dave Rubin, where he tweeted quote, I know
a lot of people who regret getting the vaccine
don't know anyone who regrets not getting it. The
people who regret getting the vaccine seem very
confused, and they seem to believe things
that are bogus. The people who regret not
getting the vaccine, many of them are dead. And
as I tweeted myself in response to Dave Rubin,
lots of the people who regretted not getting
the vaccine have since died of COVID. We heard
about a number of radio hosts who were against
vaccines, got very sick with COVID hospitalized
and said I was wrong about the vaccine. Get the
vaccine. And then they died. It's actually more
sad than anything else that this is going on,
and I continue to believe that if at age 10 11,
we start teaching kids, here's how you examine
whether your beliefs are justified by facts.
Here's how you critically analyze messages
that you get in media called media literacy
philosophy, etc. A lot of people would be
immunized for lack of a better term against ever
falling for all of this bogus, backwards thinking.
Unfortunately, we have a lot of people on the
right who don't want to teach those things because
they rightly see them as threats to right wing
ideology. The better critical thinkers people are,
the more media literate people are, the better at
understanding the concepts of epistemology
students are. It's true they're less likely to
fall for easily debunked bill right wing talking
points, and that's what scares them so much.
We'll have more on this on our Instagram.
Follow us on Instagram at David Pakman Show